hundreds remain stranded ethnic
Armenians seeking the protection of
Russian peacekeepers who now controlled
this airport in nagorno-karabakh they
fled their towns and Villages fearing
the arrival of azerbaijani soldiers
despite Baku saying that people of
Armenian descent will be protected by
the Constitution but like many here
Valeri erepatan thinks it's safer to
move on
who can give us the guarantee we found a
liter of gasoline ran away and came here
shall we go so that the young people are
killed along the way
speaking to the nation Armenian prime
minister Nicole pashinyan said the
situation remains very dangerous for the
estimated 120
000 ethnic Armenians living in the
region
Armenians continue to face the threat of
ethnic cleansing in recent days
humanitarian Aid has arrived but this
does not change the situation and unless
real living conditions are created an
effective mechanisms of protection from
ethnic cleansing than the Armenians of
nagorna Karbach will see Exile from
their Homeland
Armenians claim nagorno-karabakh as
their ancestral Homeland but the
mountainous region is internationally
recognized as part of Azerbaijan since
the fall of the Soviet Union
in 2020 Azerbaijan launched a major
offensive reclaiming territory occupied
by Armenia it led to a ceasefire
agreement between the two countries
this latest military push was aimed at
disbanding and disarming ethnic Armenian
fighters who have now surrendered their
weapons under Russian mediated agreement
this is the the Republic this is a
we opened that used to belong to
the Armenian armed forces detachments
and also illegal Armenian Armenian
forces that were here and it was seized
from them just in the last two days
during the last two days
but as Azerbaijan tightens its grip on
nagorno-karabakh International concern
is mounting about the plight of
civilians
the first humanitarian Convoy arrived in
the region on Saturday carrying 70 tons
of basic supplies ethnic Armenian
leaders say they aren't talks to
organize a withdrawal process and the
return of those displaced by the
fighting
but after three decades of rivalry
mistrust between the two sides runs deep
and many of those living here say they
wouldn't feel safe living under
azerbaijani rule but Abdul Hamid
al-jazira
is a former advisor to The Armenian
prime minister and he says most ethnic
Armenians don't want to live under
azerbaijani rule and they don't trust
its promises
we're still talking about a despotic
authoritarian regime in Azerbaijan so I
mean many of their own citizens are
deprived of many rights but there is
also an ongoing and continuous
armenophobia and xenophobia against
Armenians in in Azerbaijan I mean this
could be if ever this could be a long
process so I mean there should be
confidence building measures there
should be dialoguing there should be
some kind of a Reconciliation before we
can take talk about any kind of
integration as we saw today I mean 90 of
the people are ready to leave karabakh
now and I think they're now basically
kept hostage there we're all personally
trying to be in touch there is a little
communication it goes off and on there's
internet and cell phone communication on
and off and the people I'm talking to uh
most everyone is saying we're ready to
leave anytime so uh I think there is no
doubt in anybody's mind that after what
they saw last week or this week the new
attack renewed the attack from
Azerbaijan and the rhetoric that we
hearing from Baku people are not
imagining themselves living under
azerbaijani rule obviously people don't
want their compatriots to lose their
homes and their ancestral lands uh but
are we I don't think we're left with any
other chance I mean if these people are
under an imminent threat life threat I
don't think anybody has any choice there
is no trust in the judicial system there
is no control over how and what is going
to be the cases that could be fabricated
against the people they simply don't
like so there's little Trust on how the
azerbaijani Judiciary is going to try
Armenians and they're going to pick and
choose it's going to become a witch hunt
at least that's what we're seeing from
The Armenian side
well earlier we spoke to hikmet hajjev
foreign policy advisor to the
azerbaijani president and we ask him
about his country's offer of amnesty for
separatists who disarm in the
gorno-karabakh
as part of the 20th September of halting
the counter-terrorist actions Azerbaijan
made it very clear but who puts an
accounts down uh from the first second
karabakh war 44 Days War and the recent
engagement simply there free and here we
should differentiate two groups of
people uh one group is a serviceman of
the Armed Force of the Republic of
Armenia if they also put the gun down
and they can return back to Republic of
Armenia as part of the uh this Armament
it's also a demobilization process as
such and also local residents who were
holding their arms and if they put also
their guns down and they can return to
their barracks and from there to them
boys simply they are free and here
should be
better understanding for than everybody
what is their differentiation
differentiation we are talking about
there are some selective couple of other
people who in the first carbajo
committed crimes of all crimes against
azerbaijani civilians in a broader scale
we are talking about them and mainly
they were at the leadership of the
so-called illegal regime again this
other particular individuals and
selective individuals but we're talking
about that but with the majority male
generation male population we don't have
a problem and the Protestants with the
civilians and we shouldn't have a
problem on the contrary we are inviting
them and we are trying to reach out to
the different channels I would also
really comment the very first fact that
directly direct engagement or Central
Azerbaijan Government invited
representatives of Armenian residents of
caraba to have a direct communication
under the broad agenda of the issues
including the political integration
model social economic issues as they
asked on certain issues and central
government of Azerbaijan immediately
reacted and will continue to do so and
there are more intensive meetings are
coming forward as well to meet all of
this immediate requirements